知ってるんだから そういうことで
このもうたまたま見えますけどね
そういう体のね 病気の皮膚のね
もう大変皮膚が荒れて荒れるどころじゃない
本当にすごい悲しくなっちゃいます
見るとね でもそういう人々はやっぱり慈悲喜捨の喜の瞑想とそれなりの人々喜ぶ行為をしてあげると
嫉妬の業のカルマが消えるんです
そこで次の心はこの三十一から三十八まで
この欲界心の善心ですね
これでこの八種類のこの三十一から三十八までのこの八種類の善行為をしたならば
この八種類の結果が生まれるんですね
それは三十九から四十六まで
結果としてこの結晶する
生まれ変われる どこに生まれ変わるかというと
人間か天国なんですね
あたりまで悪いところには生まれ変われません
それで四行として二十から二十七の心は生まれるんですね
いわゆる綺麗なものを見えたり
聞きたい音楽を今みたいに聞こえたりとかね
私聞きたくないんだけど
あの音楽を聞くたびに怒ります
腹が立ちます まあで 嗅いだい香りを嗅いだりとかね
そういう風に いわゆる贅沢
贅沢できるということなんです
業害が入っちゃったな
そこでの梵天の人々にも
このそういう梵天にはこの三十一から三十八は生まれませんね
どう考えたって 生まれるかな？わからない
生まれる あ それはもう善心だからそれは生まれますけど
三十九から四十六までは生まれません
梵天には それは成熟心だから
あの結晶する心だから
梵天は違う ここで結晶しますから
でも二十から二十七までの一部は生まれるんですね
一部って着衣に眼識と耳識は生まれるんですね
それから水道あの老中水道心というのは
その三つも生まれる まあこのあのただランマナという心があるんですね
可笑縁と これはややこしいんですね
可笑縁でなんかさっぱりわからないんだけどね
で 可笑縁の問題あるんだから
こういうもう梵天の世界にもこの成熟心が生まれる可能性はあるかもしれませんし
で かなり無意味なところはね
次にこの二十七番目の説明
タターピティヘトゥカンウッカッタンクサランティヘトゥカンパティサンディンダットワーパワッテーソーラサリパーカーニリパッチャティという行
三因の初戦 初戦後は三因の結晶を与え
正気においては十六成熟心を成熟させる
で 三因三因行っていうのはこのチャートで全部書いてますから
三十一から三十八見ると三因は見つかると思います
この地相地相は三因ですね
地 水 火の心は三因ですね
この三因の場合も 優れている心と衰えている心と二つ考えているんですね
これ今まではそういう分析はなかったんだけどね
ウッカタ・オオマカっていうのはね
ここら辺に出てくるとそこまで入っちゃう
今までやったのは右行・無行の区別だけでしたけどもね
このウッカタ 優れてないっていうのはやっぱり心相の強さなんですね
やる気の強さなんですね
ですから 特に智慧の強さ
すごく智慧が働いてやると
もうすごい他の心相も強くなるんですね
中途半端でいい加減にやると心の心相は弱い
もう元気でやるぞということで
行動的で前向きに行動すると強いということで
ですから いいことをするならば
堂々と元気でやらなくちゃいけないということでね
恥ずかしがりながら誰かに隠れてとかね
というとやっぱり弱いんですね
そこで三因の心はウッカタであるならば
ショーであるならば 三因
成熟心は作るんだと いわゆる三因で生まれるんだと
それからえーと 四行として
えっとどれぐらいでしたっけ？十六
十六の成熟心が生まれる
十六っていうのはこの二十から二十七と三十九から四十六ですね
全部四行としても生まれてくる
そこで三因のオオマカ
衰えている心は三つあるんですね
また四つあるでしょ 三因の善行為なんですけど
ちょっと力弱いと その場合は
生まれる場合はデュヘートゥカン・ウッッタン・クサランジョ・デュヘートゥカン・パティサンディン・ダッタ
ああ これまとめてるんです
で 三因の衰えている四つの心と
二因の優れている四つの心
よくきめ細かく分けてるんだけど
そんなにこの論理はすごい単純なんです
二因の優れた心と三因の弱い心と
まあ力は一緒だよということなんです
そうすると心は八種類になっちゃうんですね
その八種類の心でデュエットカンパティサンデン
二因の生まれなんですね
二因の生まれの心は四つしかない
それは三十九から四十六の間で書いてるんですね
四つしかない そこで四行としては全部二因の四行ですね
そこで四つとあの 選意熟心の七つと
いわゆる二十から二十七はどうしても入ります
どうしても入ります それにそこを七つとこちらから四つ足すと十一でしょうね
こっちは八と 八と四で十二ですね
そこで次の問題なんですけど
デュエットカンオマカンという二因の衰えている心
それは四つあります 二因の衰えている心では
やっぱり二因の結晶はしないんだそうですね
かわいそうですけど 二因の結晶しないんです
わかるでしょうね あまりこのチャート見ればもうすごい明快ですから
だから八種類の善心の中で四つは二因
その二因の四つの中にも四つもまた優れている
衰えていると分けると
その中で衰え 衰えている四つの心で結果出す場合は
この下にある三十九から四十六までの心は一つも生まれてこないんだと
で 結晶する場合はどんな心で生まれるかというと
この八種類のあの 無因心の意熟心がありますね
二十 二十から二十七まで
そこでそちらの水道心で生まれちゃうんですね
で 水道心がありますね
あの 釈迦の水道心 この無因心の選意熟の中で二十七番目
それは結晶するんだけど
その心で ですから  その人にはこの八種類の心しか生まれません
こういうことなんです
僕 例を出してますから
例えば生まれつきすごいこの善心だから
過去で善行為をしたんだから地獄には行かないんですね
地獄に行かないといいところに生まれ変わらなくちゃいけないんですね
いいところといったっても
この二因心の弱い心でしたから
天国なんかは行けないんですね
それでせいぜい人間の世界なんですね
人間の世界で生まれても
生まれた結晶心が弱い
それは釈迦の水道心なんですね
それで体も弱いと 作る体も
そういうわけで生まれつき障害を持っている
お腹の中でも障害的な体を構成しちゃうんですね
だから治りはいかない
例えば目が出てこなかったならば
あとは手術してでも目を入れることはできないし
聴覚の方が故障して生まれたら
いくら苦労したってもこれ治すことはできないし
体の中 でも身体障害で生まれたら
それはもうどうしても治すことはできないし
血が脳細胞が衰えて生まれちゃったら
もうもう何もできないんですね
でも結局人間に生まれたんだから
善神の結果なんです 過去で何をしたかというと
二因心の善行為をしましたけど
この二因心自体が弱かったと
やる気があまりなくてやったんだということなんです
だから生まれ変わる時はもう違っても
そういうカルマが回ってきたら
まあ別にどうったことないというかね
まあ生まれてこなかった方が本人にとって良かったかもしれませんしね
それは心の回転だからわからない
だからこういうことを定期的に言うんですね
いつでも強い心を持って
いつでも明るい心を持ってと
余計な欲と余計な怒りを頭の中で回転させるなとかね
明るい考え方と元気な考え方と
もう精神的には元気 体は弱くたっても
それはもう気にしない
体が弱くて倒れたっても
まあ頭だけ口だけ達者でとかね
そういう明るい態度は仏教はすごく推薦しているんですね
そこで例えば障害を持って生まれたとすると
その人がいいものを見られると
いいことを聞かれると
この八種類の熟心が生まれるんですね
無因心の で それから体が弱いんだから
体の痛みやら不調やら不自由なことやら感じちゃうと
不善心がもう妨害業で入ってくるし
で 妨害業がどっと入ってきたら
その人は早く寿命を終わっちゃいますけどね
で その人にとっては世事業はどんどん世事していっちゃうと
延々と歩いて生きてなくちゃいけないんです
弱いから だからどっちか正しいと悪いということは決められない
例えば障害を持って生まれても
すごい あの 何て言いますか
世事業がいっぱい入ってきて
それでもちゃんと何か勉強して
ちゃんとね 仕事をできて
車椅子でも何でもね 堂々と自分で改良した運転できる車でも買ってもらったりとかね
そういうことをできて
普通の人間で仕事できるならば
その分は幸福かもしれませんし
それでもうそれなりにいいことをしてね
堂々と生きているならば
それはそれ 素晴らしいことでもあるし
私はすごくあの 最近 あの
薬害エイズの若者がいたんですね
で 彼がね 小さい時病院に行っても
そこもね エイズにうつってしまって
で 彼がもうあれは正真正銘の妨害業なんですね
今歩けないんですね もう今いるでしょうと思いますけどね
なかなかテレビないんだからわかりませんだけど
で まあもう二十歳ぐらいかな
二十歳ぐらい え？何？川田さん
そうそうそう で 普通の男の年で見ればすごい元気な体のはずなんです
今 杖を持ってすごいゆっくり歩いたりするんですね
でも今は一応落ち着いて何も行動してないんだけど
彼が自分がそういうことになったことによって
堂々と社会に出て喋って
他の人々のためにも素晴らしい行動をしたんですね
日本では その人をやらなかったら
この国ではね 人のために手も指も 1本も動かしませんから
自分のためだったら何でもするんだけど
ですから 私は彼が素晴らしい人やと思うんです
自分の病気に悩んだり
苦しがったり 悔しがったりするということよりは
もうそんなことがあってはならないと
で 行動する ですから すごい明るいしね
可愛いし で みんなその人を応援したくなるし
だから暴動が流行ったんだけど
それで暴動が入って それでその人殺害されますしね
で そのチャンスを生かして
自分がもう普通の人間には全くできないいい行為もしてしまったんですね
ですから もうもし彼がね
普通の男の 健康的な男の人に生まれたならば
もう何の意味もない人生で
それだったらもう母親
私の子はね もう本当に早く死ぬのはもうもう悔しいんだとかね
我慢できない それはただの欲望だけであってね
もし母親の希望通りに元気な男の子ですごい立派に
もう体見たら本当に健康的な人だったらすごいいい男になるだろうと思いますけど
だからといってどこかのサラリーマンになって
まあまあどうか誰かと結婚してね
それでも頭が禿げるまで仕事をするとね
それだけで人生終わっちゃうでしょうしね
だからわからない その人にとってはこの暴動とね
殺害業入ったことはいいことか悪いことかとね
誰が決めるんですかね
そんなものは法則だからね
そういう話も決して判断的な話じゃなくて
ただ状況を説明するだけなんですね
判断は不可能っていうのは仏教ではね
もうするなとね 時間になりました
そこでこの 28 で啓知話だというものがありまして
そこはこの 有業無業は関係あるかないかということで
ということだそうです
とにかくこの説明では有業無業が無視されてるんですね
有業無業無視されてるんだから
なんで有業無業に分かれるかと聞きたくなる私が
それでウッカットオマッタとショーとレッツと分かれてるでしょうね
それだったらその言葉 2つ捨ててしまって
それは有業無業につなげてしまえばもうもっと分かりやすいなのに
有業無業無視してショートレス入れてるんですね
だからこの これはあくまでも学問だからね
学問で解釈で そういう風にまあちょっと合わないところはあるんです
有業無業は関係ないと結局は言ってるんだから
それだったら最初から言う必要はないし
でも言わなくちゃいけない
なぜならばアビダンマ経典に有業無業のことを考えてちゃんとあるんです
あるんだから捨てるわけにはいきません
それだったらウッカットオマッタとアビダンマでない考え方使うなと
それを経典にはない考え方なんですね
ウッカットオマッタならショートレスは
ということは皆様に言ったって意味がない
それはもう大学 大学研究でいうことで
じゃあそこら辺に終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございました
[背景音]